you just look at my boobs
I was not my intention I didn't really
right now
now I did because we were talking about
testing out failed oh my god
okay he just left this one again
you never forget the one who steals your
heart or the one oh who kicks your ass
[Music]
some base you [ __ ] is happening our
Beach and my balls say we need to go
over there and check it out
good bad idea Mitch we're lifeguards my
bald a he's just thinking he's right
well my balls are saying [ __ ] that noise
let's go handle business your balls are
bullies they watch work because we
follow rules
this guy train wrecks I'm never OD and
not a single [ __ ] was given what a bet
for is in the whole world
would like if a human [ __ ] a jetski
which is impossible to be so cool don't
know don't be like me there's your cup
don't jerk off on my sheet just remember
I'm always watching no Leon occasions
manage
[Music]
Becca
All Things Considered being sure got a
lot work fine that's good luck pick it
up we need to search the morgue for
evidence Chuck's team for leader Monty
you want me to check his taint lift his
[ __ ] scrotum and check his taint -
taint man it ain't even look get closer
oh oh mai gerd oh there's the hole
that's just his bundle of smile most of
that do not post at this a head full of
ball sack she turns of canals into the
goddamn X game because we were in
lifeguard pursuit oh okay
fumble except for there's no [ __ ]
such thing as lifeguard pursuit
[Music]
you